[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles
émission spéciale l'europe soixante ans
après le traité de rome vers quelle
europe
voulons nous aller pourquoi cette
fracture entre l'europe d'un côté une
grande partie des peuples européens
pourquoi la construction européenne ne
fait plus rêver aujourd'hui et comment
relancer relancer le projet européen ces
questions on va se les poser avec nos
invités philippe juvin bonjour vous êtes
alors eurodéputés du groupe ppe le
monsieur europe du parti les
républicains soutien de françois fillon
candidat à la présidentielle merci
d'être venu à côté de vous philippe
lambertz bonjour bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputés belges coprésident du groupe
des verts ici au parlement européen
soutient de benoît hamon évidemment vide
en ciel absolument
enfin edouard ferrand beaux jours vous
êtes eurodéputés du groupe europe des
nations et des libertés est député
français au parlement européen selon
votre expression à chef de file des élus
front national au parlement européen
première délégation 1 française un
carton dernières élections européennes
24 eurodéputés effet messi au parlement
européen
23 maintenant je crois soutiennent
marine le pen de ce candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
avant de débattre et à l'heure où donald
trump annonce la perte de l'union
européenne après le break site retour
sur 60 ans de construction européenne il
ya 60 ans le traité de rome donnaient le
point de départ d'une politique commune
le récit de rabbi cas
le 9 mai 1950 robert schuman alors
ministre des affaires étrangères lance
le coup d'envoi d'une construction
européenne
après le traumatisme de six ans de
guerre l'idée d'une europe unie s'impose
la france a toujours eu pour objet
essentiel que servir la paix l'ope n'a
pas été fait
nous avons eu la guerre ne se fera pas
d'un coup
un an plus tard cette construction
européenne prend forme avec la création
du cqa la communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier
les six pays fondateurs de la cee signe
alors le traité de paris le 18 avril
1951 le 25 mars 1957 le traité de rome
instituant la communauté économique
européenne
le marché commun se met en place cette
europe devenue attractive par sa
stabilité politique et économique va
connaître plusieurs vague d'adhésions le
1er janvier 1973
elle passe de 6 à 9 avec l'entrée du
danemark des l'irlande et du royaume uni
un peuple qui depuis toujours et plus
particulièrement depuis 30 ans mais cher
entre tous et que dès maintenant j'ai le
sentiment vous trouvez ainsi non pas à
côté d'un négociateur mais à côté d'un
membre de la communauté européenne
puis viennent la grèce l'espagne et le
portugal
en 2007 l'union européenne compte 27
membres dans cette europe élargie la
libre circulation des biens et des
personnes s'impose en vertu des accords
de schengen signé le 14 juin 1985
l'accord prévoit la suppression des
frontières entre les états membres
mais un renforcement des contrôles
extérieurs pour assurer la sécurité de
ses citoyens
le 7 février 1992 avec les accords de
maastricht la cee devient l'union
européenne la mesure la plus
emblématique est sans doute la plus
controversée reste la limite de déficit
de 3% de la richesse nationale est de
60% de la dette publique
maastricht c'est aussi le lancement de
la monnaie unique européenne l'euro qui
entrera en vigueur le 1er janvier 2001
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que ça arrive il
n'y a pas eu une seule organisation
européenne que nous avons fait faire
cette façon persuadé de la popularité de
cette union le 29 mai 2005
les dirigeants français et néerlandais
lancer un référendum sur la constitution
européenne
c'est un désaveu près de 55% des
français se prononcent en faveur du non
nous allons écouter
nous sommes à l'écouté c'est le plan des
démocraties des débats de dialogue
ces institutions européennes mais aussi
les états membres nous voulons
comprendre les attentes des citoyens
européens
deux ans plus tard les dirigeants
européens tirent les leçons de cet échec
retentissant
ils se réunissent à lisbonne pour signer
un nouveau traité permettant à l'europe
de fonctionner à 27 membres
mais l'europe auparavant si attrayante
fait moins rêver
le 23 juin dernier les britanniques
votent à 51% pour sortir leur pays de
l'europe
je voudrais faire une déclaration devant
vous à propos du sommet européen et de
la décision de notre pays d'organiser la
sortie de l'union européenne la grande
bretagne a brisé le tabou de la sortie
de l'union européenne après londres
paris inquiète avec l'ascension du front
national faisant craindre une nouvelle
crise l'europe joue à nouveau son destin
voilà un sujet de rabbi cas question
toute simple 60 ans après le traité de
rome pourquoi l'europe ne fait plus
rêver
on n'en parle pas beaucoup notamment
dans la campagne présidentielle philippe
juvin l'europe ne fait plus rêver
d'abord parce qu'il n'y a pas de vision
commune entre les membres
on n'a pas su créé ça ou plutôt on l'a
oublié et puis parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'états qui n'acceptent plus les
décisions qu'on prend semblait enfin
vous avez des états qui remettent en
cause des principes fondamentaux
regardez les polonais qui utilisent le
rock comme un tiroir caisse des
milliards d'euros qui arrive en pologne
qui s'est développée grâce à l'europe et
qui aujourd'hui 10 mai l'europe on n'en
veut pas moi je vais vous dire une chose
sortir de l'europe on a trop élargir n'a
pas approfondi
on n'a pas donné de sens il faut donner
du sens politique
le vrai la vraie conséquence c'est si un
pays sort de l'union en particulier un
grand pays comme la france demain comme
plusieurs candidats le souhaitent
qu'est ce qui va se passer non seulement
il y aura des conséquences économiques
et sociales majeures avec un
appauvrissement de la population il faut
le dire c'est ça qui va se passer
et deuxièmement je mets en garde tout le
monde ça serait une folie
l'europe c'est une zone de stabilité et
vous savez avec les polonais les
lituaniens et russes qui sont devenus
absolument fou dans les dix à quinze ans
après la fin de l'union européenne
il y aura la guerre sur le continent
l'union européenne aujourd'hui n'est pas
en adéquation avec les peuples je crois
qu'il ya une fracture avec le sentiment
national d'un certain nombre d'états et
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne ne répond pas aux
besoins de ce qu'attendent aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de nations et c'est un
véritable problème parce que le débat
est complètement centrée sur le front
national dans nos séances commission aux
séances plénières et cetera
tout tourne autour de marine le pen des
populistes européens je crois que le le
traité de rome a pris dès le départ une
fausse mois
l'europe était vicié l'idée était au
contraire de construire dès le départ
une europe fondée sur une vision commune
mais les américains ont dès le départ
éviter la guerre aussi mettre en commun
et le charbon n'est plus en guerre et
par le traité de rome rouler
une vision du tout économique le
politique était subordonnée à l'économie
et je crois qu'ils ont voulu construire
ce qui n'était pas le projet de robert
schuman d'ailleurs les américains ont
imposé à travers le gat de soumettre les
nations européennes à un grand marché de
libre échange et je crois que vouloir
frauder une europe sur un modèle
économique ultralibéral technocratique a
été à mon avis le gros problème qui dès
le départ a créé le péché originel de
l'union européenne s'ils ne l'ont bien
n'est ce pas la même lecture que
monsieur ferrand je pense que l'union
européenne en tout cas le projet
européen a suscité l'adhésion de tegel
de la grande majorité des européens
aussi longtemps qu'il restait fidèle à
son projet c'est à dire comme vous le
disiez si bien assurer la paix sur ce
continent par d'une part l'extension et
la généralisation de la démocratie et
des libertés
je rappelle que deux des membres
fondateurs l'allemagne et l'italie
avaient été des dictatures donc
enraciner la démocratie et les libertés
est par ailleurs assurer une prospérité
partagée et on l'a vu pendant les trente
premières années la construction
européenne c'est ce qui s'est passé les
inégalités ont été réduites la
prospérité a réellement été partagé la
paix et la démocratie se sont installés
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un virage qui
a été pris dans les années 80 celui
rêves néo libérale et ce virage à
quelque part fait que l'union européenne
qui n'est jamais que le produit des
majorités dans les différents états
membres à abandonner ce projet de
prospérité partagée aujourd'hui on voit
les inégalités augmentent et on voit la
pauvreté l'exclusion augmenter et c'est
ça qui nourrit je pense le rejet parce
que bien souvent on met ses politiques
sur le compte de l'union européenne
parce que beaucoup de décideurs
nationaux qui siège à bruxelles ne
veulent pas admettre ou porter le poids
politique des choix politiques qu'ils
font ce qui nourrit le rejet on a parlé
beaucoup de du break 6 mai 2005 le le le
référendum le non au référendum traité
constitutionnel à l'est les partisans
disait cette europe du marché unique
cette europe de l'abaissement des
salaires de la compétition sauvage on
n'en veut pas et b et puis c'est passé
est-ce que c'est pas la coupure sept en
tout cas à des éléments quand quand vous
n'écoutez pas les messages que vous
envoie vos citoyens vous courez le
risque évidemment qu'ils se rebellent
contre vous c'est une affaire qu'ils ont
voulu faire une europe sans les peuples
et je crois que c'était un déni de
démocratie 2005 c'est justement la non
reconnaissance des aspirations des
peuples à décider d'eux-mêmes et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui un affaiblissement
des parlements nationaux au profit du
parlement européen et que une
superstructure qui se met en place ce
qu'on appelle une europe supranationale
contre l'intérêt légitime des peuples de
l'orient aurait été là et que demain
l'europe assène-t-il ernational que
c'est contre l'intérêt des peuples et si
parce que vous avez deux modèles ce
moment qui sonna s'affrontent d'un côté
vous avez un modèle de madame merkel qui
vise à créer toujours plus d'europe de
manière à pouvoir diluer un petit peu le
pouvoir d'aider natio et puis modèle
vise à redonner la souffrance chez moi
je pense que ce n'est certes plus de
souveraineté
elle se retrouve aujourd'hui dans la
montée d'un certain nombre de mouvements
politiques en europe qui vise justement
à l'esprit de nos différents moi
j'entends toutes les incantations mais
ce n'est pas parce que ça marche pas
bien qu'il faut tout casser
deuxièmement maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
propose c'est ça le sujet avec entracte
que veulent nous qu'est ce qu'on propose
nous chez françois fillon nous disons
qu'au fond l'europe il faut la refonder
autour de deux cercles un cercle de pays
qui veulent participer au marché unique
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui n'ont rien
d'eux ils dressent alliende un deuxième
cercle actuellement deuxième vitesse de
pays qui veulent aller plus loin en
intégrant plus un certain nombre de
pouvoirs je pense à l'énergie je pense à
la fiscalité je pense à la défense je
pense à l'immigration je pense à la
démocratie européenne aussi comment
est-on représentées dans les
institutions européennes
eh bien on aurait deux cercles un cercle
très intégré la france l'allemagne les
pays fondateurs levé le benelux les pays
du benelux l'italie
et puis un cercle plus grands un grand
marché mais c'est que si on ne fait pas
ça ou europe va distribuer 20 ans au
moins mais pour moi les deux bourgs les
deux vo union européenne c'est justement
l'élargissement et les traités de libre
échange aujourd'hui il ya sept pays qui
aspire à rentrer dans l'union européenne
on est déjà 28 28 bis si ça fait 34
notamment et monsieur personne en europe
ne veut l'élargissement à l'été vont
arriver la rbi est aussi depuis quand
les faits nous sommes déjà dans une
europe à plusieurs vitesses il ya
dix-neuf états qui partagent la monnaie
unique et les autres ne partage pas
sacré déjà quelque chose d'assez
radicalement différent maintenant ce qui
est clair c'est que faire une monnaie
unique et faire à marché unique sans
faire une union fiscale et sociale c'est
mettre en concurrence les systèmes
sociaux c'est-à-dire des systèmes de
protection sociale et les systèmes
fiscaux des états membres une
concurrence dont les arbitres sont les
multinationales en 99 lorsque s'est mis
en place le rouge
avec l'euro c'est plus de croissance
plus de pouvoir d'achat y aura plus de
prospérité les gens vont vivre mieux
aujourd'hui chez nous en france la fin
de mois comment souvent en début de mois
malheureusement et donc on regarde quoi
on regarde aujourd'hui les cinq pays qui
ne sont pas membres de la secte c'est à
dire la suédoise en peine deux ans il a
fui ce sont les critères c'est quoi être
bien vos confrères est la chance et
c'est quand même de ce que tout le monde
est très nationale et pays qui
aujourd'hui la meilleure croissance en
europe ce sont les pays qui ne sont pas
membres de la zone euro comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer est ce que vous
croyez réellement qu'à pays prenons
l'exemple de la france de 63 millions
d'habitants va arriver à peser dans un
système mondialisé tout seul
non évidemment c'est un succès cela doit
être un véhicule de puissance pour les
états nations c'est ça le sujet et la
france si elle veut être souveraine elle
doit avoir des éléments de puissance et
les éléments puissance il n'existe pas
quand vous êtes seul
et elle vous êtes endettés l'europe elle
protège à condition qu'on sache s'en
servir aujourd'hui nous proposons de
mieux nous en servir mais seuls nous
disparaîtrons mais si on parle beaucoup
de la percée de l'extrême droite en
europe lors des dernières élections au
pays bas donc ce n'était pas le cas
c'était une progression mais on est loin
du coeur d'une vague des populistes les
populistes sont bien avancés assez
libéral mark rutte 50 ans un chef du
gouvernement sortant qui remporte les
élections législatives stéphanie des
pierres
les pays bas ont dit non au populisme
c'est le parti libéral qui remporte
largement les législatives avec plus de
54% des voix soit 32 sièges au parlement
son chef le premier ministre marque
route se félicite d'avoir mis un coup
d'arrêt à la montée des extrêmes en
europe
c'est une soirée où les pays-bas après
le bail zitte après les élections
américaines ont dit stop aux mauvais
populisme
longtemps donné favori par les sondages
le leader d'extrême droite geert wilders
n'arrive que deuxième
son parti obtiendrait 19 sièges c'est
tout de même 4 de plus qu'en 2012 mais
loin du raz-de-marée redouté par le
reste de l'europe
l'autre surprise c'est la percée des
écologistes menés par le trentenaire y
ait ce klaver il quadruple leur score
avec 16 sièges
c'est important pour tous les autres
partis de gauche et progressistes dans
le reste de l'europe restait fidèle à
vos principes quand un populiste dit que
les réfugiés ne sont pas les bienvenues
en europe
tenez vous en à vos principes qui disent
qu'ils sont bienvenus soyez progressis
soyez fiers de vos idées et ne les
cachais pas pour gouverner marc croteau
l'actuel premier ministre va donc devoir
former une nouvelle coalition
geert wilders s'est dit prêt à y
participer mais jusqu alors tous les
autres partis ont refusé de s'allier
avec le trentenaire landais
[Musique]
voilà ce résultat aux pays-bas rassure
de nombreux dirigeants de l'union
européenne mariano rajoy en gala merkel
françois hollande se sont empressés de
féliciter leurs homologues c'est un ouf
de soulagement chez vous je ne
m'attendais pas une percée majeure de
l'extrême droite qui font 19 sièges sur
donc ça n'est c'est une force importante
mais qui reste marginal dans le débat à
la fois j'ai des motifs d'être satisfait
le reportage l'a montré mes amis
politiques les verts ont fait une
progression fulgurante et donc
s'installe clairement dans le paysage
néerlandais avec un message d'ouverture
un message pro européen un message de
justice sociale et ça montre bien qu'il
n'y a pas qu'une alternative au parti de
la pensée unique qui a car malgré tout
le premier ministre mark rutte
il y a il n'y a pas que l'alternative
des nationaux populistes il y à
l'alternative que les écologistes
peuvent incarner ceci étant les partis
qui veulent continuer sur la voie de la
pensée unique c'est à dire la mise en
concurrence des systèmes sociaux et
fiscaux au profit des intérêts privés
l'augmentation des inégalités et ces
choses là
ces partis restent majoritaires aux pays
bas et donc ça évidemment ça continue à
inquiéter il est fort probable que la
prochaine coalition néerlandaise
poursuivra dans la direction des
politiques néolibérales d'austérité mais
ça évidemment ce sont les politiques je
vois qu'il ya des inférences est de
mauvaise augure pour marine le pen la
défaite de garde viseur optique banque
défaite parce que d'abord il progresse
il prend cinq sièges de plus
le premier ministre lui les baisses je
crois qu'il ya eu la pollution de cette
affaire de l'expulsion de deux ministres
turcs qui sont venus justement dont
comme quoi un phénomène extérieur peut
polluer à une politique intérieure on a
perdu je pense l'enseignement libre
exceet dans le vrai que si tu sais quoi
c'est un le refus de la politique de
submersion migratoire notamment la
sphère de calais et deuxièmement la
directive détachement des travailleurs
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui une
aspiration des peuples européens à
pouvoir travailler dignement chez eux à
faire en sorte que l'économie soit
prospère et l'europe ne répond pas à ses
attentes
le trio infernal qu'on était hollande
juncker et merkel notamment sur l'âme
submersion migratoire avec la volonté
d'inclure la turquie dans l'union
européenne qui à mon avis est refusé par
l'ensemble des peuples européens
l'autre entité tation des travailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est avec un flux rejeté
hier à perpignan notamment sur problèmes
de la viticulture l'arrivée notamment de
travailleurs équatorien et du maghreb
c'est une distorsion de concurrence un
dumping social qui est très important et
je crois que les peuples européens ne
veut plus se voir imposer par la
commission de bruxelles l'envoi par
bruxelles et son mélange tout quand il
ya des problèmes dans les pays où on met
ça sur le dos de l'europe en général
national et voir deuxième point mal
c'est à cause de l'europe et que ça ne
s'est jamais là-dessus ensuite pourquoi
finalement le madame le pen que le cac a
perdu d'abord parce que quand vous avez
de la prospérité
quand vous avez un discours ferme sur
l'immigration sur la sécurité
quand vous dites à monsieur erdogan non
clairement avec la sphère des
manifestations et quand enfin vous êtes
européen début de luxueux et pour vous
dites que l'europe est que les quand
vous dites que l'europe est nécessaire à
la prospérité et vous le dites calmement
et bien en fait les gens vous
comprennent y voit le roi les officines
de madame le pen en fait il doit se
faire sur l'ignorance et c'est vrai sur
l'absence au nom du roi turquie c'est
que nous nous sommes opposés aux
républicains à l'entrée de la turquie
depuis toujours à vous pouvez raconter
ce que vous voulez mais c'est ça la
réalité est aujourd'hui avec ce qui se
passe chez air dogad et bien
j'effectuerai plus beaucoup de cas
sociaux l'éducation une victoire de
marine le pen à la présidentielle c'est
la fin d'une union européenne abaisse
est très clair que sa vie si marine le
pen devait être élu et si elle devait
entraîner la france sur un chemin de
sortie de l'union européenne c'est clair
que ce serait un coup extrêmement
brutale des brûlures ou si elle est
probablement fatal on n'en est pas là le
pire n'est jamais sûr je voudrais dire à
monsieur ferrand que j'ai l'habitude de
débattre avec certains de vos collègues
du front national mais j'ai rarement
rencontré des distorsions de factuel
aussi forte à y prétendre que le ppe et
pour l'adhésion de la turquie
jeudi c'est méconnaître la réalité des
choses ici au parlement européen mâle et
prétendre que la france a accueilli des
réfugiés vous voulez rire au bras ou la
main du amis ont trois cent mille
réfugiés val d'isère
henri godard et au maximum 30 milles sur
deux ans et la france en a peut-être à
l'usiné mais c'est bien voilà je veux
moi je veux bien débattre mallory il
faut qu'on parle de la même réalité moi
il faut comparer différents
il souffrait pour des avoirs parole 600
à 2 contre moi mais bon on a l'habitude
si vous voulez mais aujourd'hui je suis
membre de la délégation avec la turquie
et je peux vous dire que les
représentants à ben bravo les romains
dans le temps oui je suis mauvais moment
avec des agresseurs et bien oui alors
des régates turquie parce que je pense
que la turquie n'est pas européenne
bon au moins je suis franc là dessus et
d'ailleurs les sur ce que nous disons on
ne regarde pas ce qu'ils disent mais on
oublie alors simplement vous répondre
marine le pen veut refondre l'union
européenne elle veut recréer leur
organisation et de se pointer avec une
grande coopération tels que ça existait
avec la possibilité d'avoir toujours un
parlement européen qui sera un instances
décisionnelles consultative avec le fait
d origine de mai consultative oui avec
elle et a même expliqué ce que ça tiens
j'ai du mal
bah rien au sujet de michel mais si non
on fait dire ça ou bien ou bien c'est
dit on elle s'approchait d'eux ils ne
sont même plus français ni belge ils
sont dix ans devenu complètement heureux
là c'est à dire qu'il pense que c'est
même plus les nations qui existe c'est
un espèce de sport national qui doit
guider nos choix je suivais mes servi en
algérie
je suis aussi heureux et fiers de l'est
en fait ils sont la première marche vers
le mondialiste c'est à dire vers
l'éclatement des sociétés pour aller
vers plus d'accords de libre-échange
mois souveraineté c'est donc on s'oppose
en fait on est les seuls effectivement à
s'opposer à un autre projet parce que
nous sommes européens mais selon mais en
fait vous aimez les pensions privées que
vous proposez regardez ce que nous
faisons sur le traité de libre et jean
ce que nous faisons nous les mais nous
menons l'opposition gervais ce que nous
faisons est arrivé là sans la finance
c'est n'importe quoi ça aussi c'est
l'extrême droite la seule grosse la
seule philippe lambert dit surveillance
et philippe lambert est ce que vous êtes
plus certains eurodéputés j'ai entendu
ici et là qui serait pour proposer
l'interdiction du parlement européen aux
députés qui seraient contre la
convention européenne ma question sur
blé nationale on serait en
interprétation aussi l'utiliser lutte et
martin schulz si vous me connaissez les
vraiment pas mon avis ça n'a jamais été
mon ami je l' ai combattu depuis des
années vous êtes je dis simplement que
tout élu du peuple à la même dignité la
même représentativité la même légitimité
il n'est pas question pour moi de
d'interdire ou de restreindre les droits
de quelques élus que ce soit les élus
la démocratie c'est le combat des idées
c'est la confrontation des idées et donc
en effet je ne suis pas d'accord avec
monsieur ferrand
mais il est aussi légitime que moi pour
s'exprimer dans cette enceinte très bien
monsieur ferro a le droit de dire ce
qu'il veut même quand il dit n'importe
quoi alors un des points qui fait mal
erreur l'europe ce sont les
délocalisations à la cessation
d'activité dans un pays et le transfert
de cette production dans un autre état
une délocalisation sur deux se fait à
l'intérieur de l'europe c'est ce que
déclare jean-luc mélenchon qui veut
lutter contre le dumping social alors
vrai ou faux c'est notre rubrique
checkpoint préparé par thomas mignon les
délocalisations au sein de l'union
européenne jean luc mélenchon la sueur
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire la chine et l'inde ne sont pas
les destinations les plus courantes
si vous ne retirez pas les traités qui
interdisent l'harmonisation sociale
nous allons continuer les deux
localisations puisqu'une sur deux se
fait à l'intérieur durant cinquante pour
cent des délocalisations aurait donc lui
au sein même de l'union
alors quelle est l'ampleur de ce
phénomène il faut savoir qu'il n'existe
aucun inventaire en la matière
lorsqu'une usine est fermée dans un pays
pour être ouverte dans un autre elle
n'est pas tenu de l'annoncé alors tenir
à l'oeil tous ces mouvements relèverait
de l'exploit
les huits étude s'est penchée tant bien
que mal sur le sujet en se basant sur
les délocalisations annoncé dans la
presse au fumet d'années elle a recensé
7 152 cas entre 2003 et 2016 et parmi
eux 352 avait pour destination les
relocalisations un autre état membre de
l'union
cela fait environ 47% il semble donc que
jean luc mélenchon soit effectivement
dans le vrai mais regardons un instant
les délocalisations sous l'angle des
pertes d'emplois engendrées lors des ses
150 de délocalisation en europe un peu
moins de deux cent mille emplois ont été
perdus et parmi ces deux cent mille
emplois environ 120 milles peuvent être
attribués un transfert de la production
vers d'autres états membres
cela signifie que l'équivalent de 60%
des cas observés
ont été relocalisés au sein de l'union
plus sous l'angle des emplois le
phénomène très européen et donc encore
même plus important quoi qu'il en soit
une délocalisation sur deux souffre et
elle à l'intérieur de l'union
[Musique]
on a c'est vrai le doping sociale la
relance du projet européen est ce que ça
passe par une europe sociale ah oui
absolument
absolument parce que au-delà du
mécanisme d'aidé glocalisation c'est la
mise en concurrence des travailleurs des
différents pays avec des régimes de
protection sociale très différents qui
même pour les travailleurs qui gardent
leur emploi au pays poussent les
standards à la baisse et donc ça il faut
sortir de cette logique de concurrence
effrénée entre les états membres pour
aller vers une logique de convergence
établissements de minima sociaux partout
en europe
et puis leurs convergences graduelle
c'est ce qu'on a fait au moment où
portugal l'espagne et la grèce ont
rejoint on a véritablement observé un
rattrapage de ces trois pays avec le
reste de l'humour ce sont 2000 année
selon berry entre temps mais en train de
changer
'l'annonce ce sont des choses et le son
des mots vous devez vrai que l'homme
était aussi un grand terrorisme en 2007
par contre est fait dans la période néo
libérale ou là ça a été la concurrence à
outrance avec une pression à la baisse
edouard ferrand après vous est bon on
pourrait demander à monsieur juncker
aussi pourquoi est-ce qu'il a protégé
les grandes multinationales chez lui 1
c'est le constat que nous avons combattu
c'est pas lourd nous on est content la
directive détachement des travailleurs
qui étaient une catastrophe économique
et social pour l'europe ce qu'on veut
nous c'est le patriotisme économique
c'est à dire aider les nôtres avant
d'aider les autres je crois
qu'aujourd'hui une disproportion de
concurrence au niveau de la monnaie
notamment entre les différentes nations
et qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui faire
l'économie de vouloir justement remettre
à pain à système social et fiscal
il faut aller vers la paix et une autre
sans orient offrant avec un franc faible
par rapport aux autres
si on abandonne l'euro évidemment ça va
pas être plus haut niveau des
importations qui volent dans le chef
dont marine le pen l'a annoncé il y aura
un référendum c'est les français qui
choisiront aujourd'hui on a une monnaie
qui écoute moi d'évaluer qui n'a plus
aujourd'hui les qualités d'être pour la
france et se croit qu'il faut justement
repenser tout le système de l'euro
pourquoi les entreprises délocalisent
d'abord parce qu'en france il ya
beaucoup de charges et charges en france
sont considérables et donc nous allons
baisser les charges et donc il y aura
moins d'intérêt délocaliser deuxièmement
nous allons lutter contre le dumping
social et fiscal européen aujourd'hui il
ya des telles distorsions entre les pays
de l'ocs que des chefs d'entreprises
français aux intérêts
délocalisée dans d'autres états
européens et ça nous allons lutter
contre ça et enfin troisièmement nous
allons favoriser par un bail ukraine
actes un acte qui permettent au marché
public de choisir d'abord des
entreprises européennes de lutter contre
les délocalisations en dehors de la zone
euro ce que je vous dire c'est très
simple l'europe ça protège parce que
c'est un grand marché pour les
entreprises françaises aussi mais à
condition qu'on le dompte nous ce que
nous voulons c'est dompter le rendre
capable de rouler en sorte que l'europe
favorise la création d'emplois
ça tient il n'y a pas d' europe unie il
n'y a pas d'union douanière je crois que
l'europe aujourd'hui à abc toutes ces
barrières douanières et qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous sommes non
seulement en compétition à l'intérieur
des 28 états mais aussi avec tous les
traités de libre échange qui
affaiblissent encore plus le jour non
vous oublierez l'âge de lin de l'europe
et de l'euro est bien le pouvoir d'achat
des français va plonger on prend effet
le froid nouveau sera dévalué
probablement de 40% regarder les
britanniques ne sont pas encore sorties
la livre a déjà perdu en dix ans
personne n'en parle
expliquez-moi pourquoi eh bien ce sera
le mot de la fin merci à vous trois
d'être venus débattre en toute
démocratie a ici au parlement européen
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis à
l'europe à 60 ans c'est pas mal bail
merci
[Musique]